-Our next guests
just announced a U.S. tour
kicking off next spring.
Performing the title track to
their album, "Dripfield,"
please welcome Goose!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ How did he let down ♪
♪ How did he get down in it ♪
♪ How did he show them ♪
♪ How did he hold them in it ♪
♪ How did he come to ♪
♪ How did he run true
through it ♪
♪ How was it in full ♪
♪ Boundless and simple ♪
♪ Love ♪
♪ Lonely roam ♪
♪ Onerated soul ♪
♪ Oh, the rain it calls ♪
♪ Howling up ♪
♪♪
♪ Season come ♪
♪ Oh, the reeds you run ♪
♪ Such a heedless one ♪
♪ Climbing out ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, there I hear
him stepping ♪
♪ Overhead in heaven ♪
♪ Oceans still I'm treading ♪
♪ Turned out to the retting ♪
♪ Caught under the crescent ♪
♪ Undertow I fell in ♪
♪ Water I keep pressing ♪
♪ Down ♪
♪ Holy one ♪
♪ Constellated sum ♪
♪ Separated from ♪
♪ All above ♪
♪♪
♪ Love lit hue ♪
♪ What's a naked view ♪
♪ If I'm adjacent you ♪
♪ Always ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Still can't see what
I'm keeping on my back ♪
♪ Mmm ♪
♪ Howling out the prism ♪
♪ Calling for the rhythm ♪
♪ Time's my only prison ♪
♪ Dripfield where you sitting ♪
♪ Rising like the weather ♪
♪ Blood gets pumping redder ♪
♪ I know that life
comes better ♪
♪ In love ♪
♪ Holy one ♪
♪ Constellated sum ♪
♪ Separated from ♪
♪ All above ♪
♪ Hull undone ♪
♪ Saturated tongue ♪
♪ Oh, the rain it comes ♪
♪ Howling out ♪
♪ Love lit hue ♪
♪ What's a naked view ♪
♪ If I'm adjacent you ♪
♪ Always ♪
♪ Season wide ♪
♪ Everlasting tide ♪
♪ It's coming back just like ♪
♪ Always ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]